اعلن الرئيس الكيني ويليام روتو اتفاقه مع
الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو على
ارسال بعثه الى الخرطوم للقاء طرفي نزاع
وحذر الرئيس الكنيم تداعيات القتال في
السودان على امن وسلم المنطقه والعالم
باسره وقال ان هناك خطرا حقيقيا من اي
ورطه تصاعد العنف لاعبين خارجين اقليميين
ودوليين ما يؤدي الى ازمه امنيه وانسانيه
وادعى الرئيس الكني قاده الطرفين
المتحاربين الى الالتزام بقرار منظمه
ايجاد خلال قمتها الاحد الماضي بما يشمل
وقفا فوريا للاعمال العدائيه والسماح
بالعبور الانساني غير المشروط والتعاون
الكامل مع مهمه قاده ايجاد حتى بل حين
يصلون الى الخرطوم واوضح ان تلبيه هذه
الشروط والانخراط في المحادثات ضروريان
للعوده الى المفاوضات بشان الاتفاق
الايطالي